[Music]
i think richard branson is not a
wonderful person so before the before
the podcast there's this video of him
what year is that video 99
or something is it in the world yeah
it's in it's in um it's on youtube and
if you google richard branson selma
hayak it's richard branson is on the
conan o'brien show selma hayek obviously
like one of those beautiful awesome
women on earth
richard branson comes on
sits selma on his lap and like is
clearly flirting i think he's like
kissing her neck like it's
[__] embarrassing it's what it is and
i whenever i saw that video i was like
oh i don't look up to you anymore that
that that was pretty bad you watched
that video
yeah i did you sent it i watched part of
it it was kind of uncomfortable so i
just stopped watching it because he kind
of like
like are they friends are they cool like
you know dude even if you are cool
that's weird to me that behavior is
weird to me and then i'm like was this
cool in 1998 did people do this type of
thing in 1990 no man i really remember
even the crowd it was like
it's it's uncomfortable and it's on live
tv and she's trying to like be polite
and not make a big deal out of it yeah
you could tell she's not like down with
that and i read his book i read his book
and like so i'm not on board with him
anymore actually so that's what that's
i'll leave it at that is that a fair
assessment no hold on hold on what what
did you read in his book or is that
irrelevant to what yours oh he was just
cheating on his wives and
and he just seemed like a guy who um
it's okay that he has his lifestyle but
i could see how that could put a lot of
people uncomfortable and easily cross
lines even if his intentions aren't
to cross a line you know what i mean
like he was like a hippie a little bit
you know what i'm saying so this is
truly the play i hate this ball because
you're hating the player here right like
yeah this guy
you know like richard branson
first of all the guy looks like he's
always having a great time you ever
watch this guy on necker island you go
see these dudes videos i think that's
part of the shtick
yeah there's definitely like once the
jeffrey epstein stuff came out you're
like oh wait what are these really rich
people doing on these islands like
what's going on over here do i need to
like
you know like make a note you know tell
my daughter like never ever go with a
billionaire to an island like you know
what i think that's a safe rule i think
that's a safe rule
right
that's a good rule i'm down with that
i'm gonna write that one down yeah put
that on the refrigerator i'm okay with
that one
yeah so i i don't know like i don't know
what he what wrong doing he's been
accused of he's pretty inspiring as
it goes and that's what i'm saying i
don't know if there's any accusations
i've got zero proof of anything i'm
saying other than just one video and
just a vibe it's just a vibe it's just
an energy
yeah you're coming in strong with a
pretty wild uh wild portrayal of no but
no i'm saying it's all energy i'm saying
that there's zero proof other than this
one video that i saw that's it that's
all i'm saying
um okay and the second one
so there's this guy named naveen jane do
you know who this guy is he's always on
like the cover of ink and he's always on
like these tony robbins things and he's
incredibly charismatic he's got a good
smile let me tell you about this guy so
do you know anything about him
i know a lot about him but i want you i
want you i want you to say the story
because i don't think most people know
anything about him all right so
even to this day he's considered a
billionaire and he's like i said he's on
the cover of all these magazines as this
like wonderful entrepreneur so i'm going
to give like a high level summary of his
background so started at microsoft in 89
probably got wealthy from that uh in the
early or mid to late 90s he started a
company called infospace uh infospace
went public and he eventually was worth
like eight billion dollars what
infospace dud
did was
it's kind of hard to explain because
it's so old and we don't even use that
anymore but like they like help to make
like directories and um maps that you
would put on your website so like just
stuff that isn't even relevant anymore
but it was just like a dot com uh
business and the stock went public and
crushed it was at 138
and then it completely crashed and in
march of 2000 it was now worth a dollar
56.
and infospace they use a ton of
controversial uh accounting
methodologies and so they said that they
made 46 million dollars in profit but
they got sued or and people got angry at
them and because in reality they
actually lost almost uh 300 million
dollars and a ton of their employees
filed suit along with a lot of their
shareholders filed suit because they uh
promised employees like different stock
options and it just went to [__] and it
was kind of built on like a bunch of
lies and
a little bit of vaporware
so that happens in 2003 he this guy jane
is uh ordered to pay 250 million dollars
for violations i don't know what uh sure
i don't know if you i don't know if you
said this but basically the the
stockholders so the employees the
stockholders they all lost their money
but he ended up making out rich off of
infospace you said that part or no no
but yeah that was like the biggest part
uh so like he sold a lot of his stock
and he made a huge sum of money a lot of
the other people did not
right
then after that he starts this other
company have you heard of this other
company called uh how do you pronounce
it intellis intellius
the best way to describe it and i think
a lot of people know what this is but
whenever you get like a
scam phone number to your phone and you
google it and you search on google and
it says like which number came up and
you type it in and it's like well and
you get all these ads like for the
background check of this person just
entering their information and you
inevitably enter in your mom and dad's
information to see like oh have my
parents ever been arrested let's find
out and it says like well we found donna
parr in missouri you could for only 18
you can get her criminal history report
and you're tricked into buying a 19 a
month subscription and i actually posted
in a picture if you look at the picture
on the doc of the actual scam but
basically this company grew to be really
big hundreds of millions in revenue and
then it came out that they were getting
sued constantly because consumers were
like i didn't know that i was signing up
for this and i've been getting billed
twenty dollars a month twenty dollars
yeah twenty dollar subscription i'm
getting billed for because the font in
like size two underneath the this check
box said like by the way this is gonna
charge you money every month yes and the
actual landing page that i sent to you
it's a screenshot and it says something
like get ten dollars for giving us
information about yourself but then also
underneath that in a really small
writing it says and after that we charge
you 19 a month
like for this and that and so it's
pretty scammy now here the reason one of
the reasons why he's on the cover of all
these magazines is he's starting a
company that helps uh mine minerals on
different planets that sounds cool and
everything but
the fact that like he has had this
history of of shadiness i think i'm not
on board with that
yeah so just to kind of like recap here
i think the uh the story is
he um
he was found guilty of insider trading
he then tried to sue his
law firm saying you didn't provide me
adequate legal coverage blah blah blah
and then
he ended up getting hit with a 247
million dollar
uh i don't know if you've got 24 247
million dollars or he made 240 no he had
to settle he had to pay
he had to pay a hundred million dollars
i think um
i'm not i'm not 100 sure on that i gotta
go look for that um and then antelius
just sold to a private equity company
after all that kind of like uh
you know after all that that hot water
um and then now is he so he's doing the
moon mining thing i've seen that he and
he has another thing that measures like
you're you're i think it just like
measures your poop doesn't it it's like
your gut stuff and
um i don't know much about that yeah
yeah that one uh the you saw that one
like the the fbi or somebody they get
the whole company's got office got
raided
because the founders were like um you
know like basically lying or cheating or
some crime basically and then the
founders got kicked out this company had
raised a bunch of money
um
i don't know the exact story here let me
let me look that up no i think you're
thinking of biome versus volume
oh okay and i think they did the exact
same thing but uh so that's why i said i
i thought the same thing i was like i
remember this couple they looked like a
couple and they got a couple okay so
that's biome not vyam i think but that
doesn't even matter i think that if you
are like this prolific in terms of like
even if you're accused this often of
stuff it doesn't mean you did it but it
means like
hmm like why does this what's the common
denominator here it's you right what's
going on here
yeah
so anyway
that's that's my list
[Music]
you